hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is a candy crush soda saga level 145
walkthrough tutorial this is a tough
level it's been changed a couple times
but it's still it's a little managed
more manageable now that's still pretty
hard so this is one people asked about a
lot so I thought I'd go ahead and make
this walk through some tips the first
thing you need to do is get rid of the
coils that are in the middle like I just
did you don't really have to worry about
too much else just try to get them out
as fast as you can that way that if you
do make some specials they'll actually
do some damage and then we're going to
fan out a little bit and we don't really
need to worry about this bear in the
middle he sort of takes care of himself
so what we're really trying to do from
the beginning to the end is just fan to
the left and right make specials and
especially we're gonna need some we're
gonna need some color color bottoms and
coloring candies if possible so
we've set up the stripeless wrapped here
that's pretty good one of the when we
got a color bomb as we fall one of the
things that you'll notice is that
Cascades you can pick up a lot of
Cascades once this once the space is
cleared out and so even though we have
the color bomb there we don't really
need to use it right away instead we'll
try to set up a combo like this one and
you're gonna well let's just say we're
gonna need quite a few of those because
here's a coloring candy up top and it
looks like we can make that into a combo
right away but we're going to need a few
because and we can't make the color bomb
above this because that oh well I guess
it would I think with this go this way
it would have made another coloring
candy but the coloring can because the
strike is good so we'll just go ahead
with that but since there are coils
underneath the honey on the sides that's
also gonna make it so where that you
know our combos and things aren't going
to be as devastating as they would be if
it was clear so we've got a lot of
different choices here I'm just kind of
hoping with that would lead the set up
for the color ball meditating
all right so we have 19 moves which is
pretty good we got to the Bears Colin
but we still need to be really careful
here to try to pick the best thing and
there was no color bombs or common
carriers that I saw so what I try to do
instead was make a cascade and that
worked out pretty good you just want to
look around and see if you see the gaps
set up already and then you would you
know drop the fifth piece soon or
whatever you know now I have the gap
down here but I can't quite bring
another red one down yet so I'm just
gonna sort let that hang
got that green out of the way so that it
wouldn't set it off and there's another
color going for us and you know again I
pretty much want to use this in a combo
that's the plan but well here we can
make a stripe with the red and then
that's ball that will fire off though um
let's see if you match the orange well
here we go now we can make a fish and
match that with the color dog so that'll
work
I just went ahead and hit some of the
ice because some of the fish are going
to go to the right side they're not
going to do any good so though just give
us more action and we only have 5 moves
left so you still need to be careful all
right now we're down to the last one and
I think we can just go ahead and make
this right rat plus striped and that
will probably hit the rest in the
Cascade or something
yep all right so that's how it goes so
keep in mind when you're playing you
want to get rid of all the coils in the
middle right away if you can and then
fan to the sides and just look for color
bomb matches set them up if you don't
have them you're not gonna be able do it
every single time it took me a couple
tries to get past and that you know I'd
beaten it when it was much harder than
this so it's still difficult you're
gonna have to hang in there and wait
till you get the right board but if you
follow those tips you'll get it sooner
than later and you'll be able to move on
so I hope this helps make sure you like
the video if you thought it was useful
subscribe to support our Channel and
we'll be seeing you soon thanks